if you noticed smoke off state route 160  today it was from a prescribed fire the  u.s forest service does these table  improve forest health and protect our  communities from devastating wildfires  today's was held in the poduci project  area in the spring mountains  officials burned dry vegetation and  other fuels that could  possibly feed a wildfire they say  preparation like this can actually help  save lives  this project's very important to us  because we have a few  camps with some children that use it in  the summertime and also adults  throughout the whole year and it's been  evacuated this area has been evacuated  due to  wildland fires approximately five times  over the last 10 15 years  more prescribed burns are scheduled in  the coming months as conditions do allow  for more  information head to eight newsnow dot  com